Marvel fans, you can all breathe a sigh of
relief the cinematic universe you know and
love isn't about to get any more complicated
than it already is.
Before he made his MCU debut as the eyepatch-wearing
S.H.I.E.L.D.
badass Nick Fury, Samuel L. Jackson was part
of another huge movie franchise: Star Wars.
There, he played Mace Windu, the revered Jedi
Master who wielded an purple-bladed lightsaber
and sat on the Jedi High Council in the final
years of the Galactic Republic.
"You refer to the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the Force.
You believe it's this… boy?"
Fans love that Jackson is part of two universally-loved
film series, and they nearly flipped their
lids when the MCU finally made a wink at that
fact.
If you'll recall, Jackson's Nick Fury mentioned
Star Wars in Spider-Man: Far From Home, when
he told Tom Holland's Peter Parker that he
wouldn't understand the Shakespeare quote
"uneasy lies the head that wears a crown"
because "it wasn't a Star Wars reference."
That led many to question why Peter a confirmed
Star Wars enthusiast, as established by the
events of Captain America: Civil War and Spider-Man:
Homecoming didn't comment that Fury and Mace
Windu look exactly alike when he officially
met the S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent in Far From Home.
It also caused some Marvel fans to theorize
that perhaps Fury and Windu are the same person
or, at the very least, that Fury may have
been leading a double life as an actor.
“OH COME ON!”
Now, we have an official answer to the question.
Avengers: Endgame directors Joe and Anthony
Russo confirmed during an appearance on Lucasfilm's
YouTube web series The Star Wars Show that
Fury and Windu aren't the same person, Fury
isn't the actor who portrayed Windu in the
Star Wars franchise, and there's no MCU plot
hole to patch up now that Fury made a Star
Wars reference.
Sorry theorists this Marvel myth has been
busted!
"You… have lost."
"No…
NO!
NO!!"
Anthony explained that all Marvel actors who
have also appeared in the Star Wars world,
well…
"They just look like those characters."
Well, yeah… we figured.
But the tongue-in-cheek speculation sure was
fun while it lasted.
The Russo Brothers' explanation actually clears
up several other mysteries of this particular
sort.
If Fury just looks like the guy who played
Windu, then one can assume that Paul Bettany's
Vision simply bears a striking resemblance
to the person who played Dryden Vos, the leader
of the crime syndicate Crimson Dawn as seen
in Solo: A Star Wars Story.
The same goes for Donald Glover: he played
Aaron Davis in Spider-Man: Homecoming and
young Lando Calrissian in Solo so, within
the new rules of the MCU, Davis only looks
like the actor behind Calrissian.
Heck, this rule can be applied to every Star
Wars actor who has also appeared in a Marvel
movie: Natalie Portman, who was Queen Padmé
Amidala in the Star Wars prequels and will
reprise her Thor franchise role as Jane Foster
in Thor: Love and Thunder; Ben Mendelsohn,
who was Director Orson Krennic in Rogue One:
A Star Wars Story and Talos in Captain Marvel
and Spider-Man: Far From Home; and Felicity
Jones, who portrayed Jyn Erso in Rogue One
and unassuming assistant to Harry Osborn,
Felicia Hardy, in The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
Thanks to Joe and Anthony Russo's explanation,
all these stars don't damage the fabric of
the MCU or the Star Wars franchise by appearing
in both film series.
Though it's less riveting than the notion
that each pair of characters are the same
person and that there's some wild Lucasfilm-Marvel
Studios inter-connectivity on the horizon,
it keeps the MCU from becoming more difficult
to understand.
After all, we're already nearly two dozen
flicks in!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.